hi i'm natasha i play helena hi i'm
shawn
i play sam i'm toby i play campbell i'm
jacques i play will
hi i'm alex i play uh harry i'm kathryn
newton and i play ally pressman
and i'm gideon and i play becca and we
are the cast of the society
[Music]
oh you sean he's
always getting me
like the best prankster accepted i
accept it i can't defend myself on that
one i accept it yeah
so you screw around a lot so that's true
but this dude he's a prankster he is
what yeah you you know only
well this is all very consistent jacques
is very
politically and socially just like he's
with it yeah he gets it
and he's the tallest and whoever's the
tallest is automatically the mayor
i'm agnostic i'm not christian secondly
i don't support guns
and i don't know if i want to get
married so how am i like my character
probably cat oh my gosh you guys i am
not like ally at all like no one would
ever listen to me
that's redeeming thank you
[Music]
we all went over to catherine's house
one day and all she had was goldfish
yeah
in her fridge
how are you still walking
[Music]
this one was always this one that cat
means yeah
catherine yeah it's all made up oh man
it didn't take a long time
because everybody would go through hair
and makeup as i was in hair and makeup
so i got to see everyone
and say good morning to everybody
oh one take merrell oh my god stop
that's just um no you guys everybody did
that
everybody did that you did that you did
that everybody
sean did that remember that long scene
whatever you know the one i'm talking
about everything right next question
oh yeah
oh we have a meme um oh there's a
nameplate
everyone jose is really good he's not
here right now jose's been making all
these uh
all these all these great he's a number
one grizz fan page
he changed the wikipedia page of the
show to be
all about three it's all about grins
oh my nicole
sleeping a few times on set too really
in the street
and you use my character we worked so
late i like to sleep in my character
event all the time and people were like
where is alex we need to we need to go
we're going to turn over and i'll be
like uh
check my bed
[Music]
jose yeah he's not here
jose gordy i would agree with that jose
yeah
100 hands down so did you give any
relationship with us
hell yeah oh my god all the time she's
like a different thing
[Music]
wait you gave people stones i gave you
crystals i'm just kidding
you still have them
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
he's the party just point yourself
yeah he's the party he's the party
animal
[Music]
natasha that's the topic
selfie queen we'll take them together
i'm the only one who gets the pictures
i'm like you guys would take a photo
let's take a picture everyone hates it
and then later we all love it
it's true it's true hey we all loved it
kathy oh i love you
[Music]
i know about a lot of indigenous
medicines actually true that you get
hiking all the time you know
yeah he owns he owns hiking boots
i'd be the first to die
everyone was doing it alex alex
alex yeah can you do one impression can
you do ally
now they
have you done one of me no yes i think
any time you do any of them
you can't ask a magician
watch the society on netflix
[Music]
you